as well looking for an update on the
interns well do it because I'm about to
give you one and they're buying the game
they're playing they're in there right
now they're shooting each other every
single time we go on like they're only
be like you know one server time we
would get everybody together and go on
so you never had options right now is
the first time in the game do you be
playing some people to be like not
feeling these guys leave and go put some
other people like every single press
would we wrote like amazing things like
leading out to it and an actual view
that I I'm looking for more content it's
like half cup I've kind of played
everything it's like well yeah you have
but not the people that bought it it's
like you've had it for like two months
and nothing was even out yet for it very
similar both on oculus and by the
reviews are very similar if you remember
to when the iPhone came out pocket
computer that you can interact with like
it's kind it's kind of new it's kind of
different people seem to be interested
in this like they're gonna happen other
like or by just go away but then in high
tech it could never go away
we had a lot of good submissions so it
was really tough that's a good a quarter
I'm too I'll race you there I love my
idea I want to have is to be able to
separate the hologram from the video
footage itself so that I can download
just the hologram so that way we can
take the entire hololens and put it on
top of say a red camera and basically
just record the whole thing with the red
camera and use tracking data from the
hololens on top of the red camera
download that and then just composite it
together well it's just the same either
way just as much one way as it is the
other you know okay Venice is just as
cool I'll come up with some others that
are just as good
you
I have no idea what's going on get
trickshot your way out of this one red
welcome to paradise smoothies are so
good we had two people that we reached
out to that we really really liked one
of them is coming in Monday to do his
editing test and the other one is
finishing school so he's not gonna be
coming in tell like the end of may be
drawn out a little bit but we'll see
what happens with the guy on Monday now
the tests to become an intern that's not
cool
is it the chaperone mode is that what's
called or when you can actually see
everything yeah yeah I finally did that
the first time last time it's like
oculus so well right now the vibe
is definitely way better in most regards
I guess it's a little more expensive so
that's not technically better it's like
yeah they're both cars but one happens
to have all these really nice features
that you want to use all the time
particular for two yeah I had like a
whole year to spend with the thing
they're like oh after using this for a
while I want to not step on my cat I
finally made the first demo soccer where
digger you remember like the first time
you started in like After Effects were
you're like I didn't think I could do
the effects and you're like not you feel
effects kid like get in there for you
know you're like whoa this is a robust
tool that can do anything that Holly we
can do in the same way like unities at
that point where it's like it's our
poking our like wait I can make a game
you know just like you can make a 3d
thing in max or Maya yeah you need to
get in a Mortal Kombat deathmatch with
OB you can't win because if OB dies well
Ren's just gonna freak out and somebody
else is going to dies you have to be
able to build a Minecraft costume out of
cardboard in ten minutes
thirdly you have to be able to edit a
vlog in five minutes with an hour of
content you have to be able to do a
stunt fall off the top of the building
onto a mat it's gonna be tough you know
we're going to start with two and
there's a possibility that they might
not make it in which case we'll go to
options three and four and just kind of
go carry on down the line we have three
days in between today and the day that
we're supposed to be shoot
miss and he hasn't sent me the s o W yet
so I told them if he doesn't get it to
us today we're dropping the project